thank you here's what's happening in the
tech world samsung has unveiled its
galaxy
s21 lineup three sizes to choose from
including the top of the line
s21 ultra the phones feature a new
contour cut
camera housing for a sleek new look the
ultra has
four camera lenses a new vlogger view
lets you record the front and back
cameras at the same time
the highest end s21 ultra is now
compatible with the stylus which is sold
separately
but an s pen from a note will work the
phones are available on january 29th
starting at 800 dollars for the s21
while the top of the line ultra will
start at
1200 google smart speakers are getting a
new more
private guest mode just say hey g turn
on guest mode and you can still use
commands but they won't be saved in your
google account history
guest mode can handle things like
questions timers and music
but google assistant won't be able to
share any personalized results like
calendar entries
you can always turn off the secret new
mode by saying hey g
turn off guest mode keep in mind anyone
can turn it off
environmental group nrdc says the latest
gaming consoles consume
more power than previous generations and
to get the maximum energy savings
you'll want to change some default
settings the xbox series x
and playstation 5 draw more power than a
60 inch tv
the entry level xbox series s is the
most energy efficient of the bunch
they recommend changing the xbox power
setting to energy saving
versus instant on which is how it ships
nrdc
studies also found that using a gaming
console to stream movies and shows
consumes 10 to 25 times more energy
than using a streaming stick to watch
the same thing
you can find links to everything i talk
about here in techsmart on my website
just go to
rich on tech dot tv i'm rich demero and
you
are tech smart